okay she's to blame because she's she's
allowing herself to you know run away
with all these Fantastical ideas but
also the dating coach I think the dating
coach is taking her for a ride and it's
just like I'm gonna just leave you to it
and get the money and then now she's
fending if the dating coach actually
said I want you to actually meet this
man who is willing to give 200k whatever
then that's something but she I think
she's definitely been played no I looked
up the dating coach
she was hotter hotter girls get better
results surprising and I'm just like and
it's so sad because she she's the the
dating coach is making her believe yeah
you can get what I know but what I've
got that's what